[Musique]
ils étaient près de 400 aidants et aidés
à participer à cette 10e édition de la
journée nationale des aidants c'est au
village corail que le département a mis
en place des stands de réflexologie de
massage et de bien-être
ben justement je vais aller faire mon
comment dirais-je le massage de
bien-être soit le dos ça va être
bénéfique pour moi aujourd'hui là je
vais en profiter au maximum
c'est un moment de plaisir
un moment de repos on va dire ma grande
et là c'est un moment de repos il se tut
de la possibilité de parler avec
d'autres personnes comme moi d'autres
aidants comme moi et on avait donc pour
thématique cette année là n'ont su
diagnostic parce que cette personne est
perdu tout seul face à un corps médical
qui n'a pas non plus la formation on va
dire pour expliquer décemment à ces
personnes ce qui va se passer et c'est à
partir de ce moment qu'ils doivent être
prises en charge à la réunion ils sont
près de 50000 aidant à s'occuper d'une
personne porteuse d'un handicap ou d'une
pathologie mobilisant tu le département
par l'intermédiaire du gps ap groupement
d'intérêt public pour le développement
des services à la personne propose des
dispositifs d'accompagnement et de
soutien aux aidants notamment à travers
des café des aidants qui sont organisées
sur tous les territoires des matinées
santé des matinées information formation
afin d'aider les aidants est d'aider et
d'accompagner les aidant dans leur lot
quotidien
nous avons mis en place aussi des
solutions de répit à travers la bourse
d'heures donc ce sont des solutions de
répit à domicile permettant aux aidants
de pouvoir de temps en temps souffler et
vous voyez ces personnes qui sont les
aidants familiaux mérite toute notre
attention et notre connaissance parce
que ce sont des gens qui donnent de leur
temps qui donne de la solidarité et
aussi de la volonté de leur amour quoi
accompagner ces personnes en souffrance
et le département doit être
reconnaissant
c'est pour cela la joie d'être des
aidants est essentielle merci
tous les aidants un village corail
transformée en piste de danse et en
ateliers détente pour nos aidants qui le
temps de cette journée seront au coeur
de toutes les attentions
[Musique]